how do you write a great scene
okay right a great you know writing a
great scene is
is it one of the
strangely hardest things you can do as I
think the writing piece of all the stuff
we have to do in filmmaking is the
hardest part that because that's where
it all begins that's the foundation that
your entire house is built on
and when you're building this house
the easiest thing to do
is your you get your house done and
you're looking at it
and you're like
something looks off it doesn't look a
little level and you'll get notes and
they'll the notes will come back and say
yep it's probably because your house is
red
if you paint it green it might not look
off so you'll paint it green and it's
still off but it's because the
foundation isn't right
and the foundation of scene work is is
really
amazingly hard to do amazingly hard to
do
um
what I've learned especially over the
last few years in depth is
how tricky it is to come up with scenes
that work and I think the best way you
can learn this is through watching plays
plays now every not every filmmaker but
a lot of the filmmakers I talk to they
always say I just can't write small I
just can't write simple
uh
I get that because oh I want to go into
outer space and fly a ship around and I
want to plan it to explode well that's
great I do too but what that can be
it can be the filmmaker waving their
arms in front of the camera saying I
don't have a story so I'm going to
distract you with all of these
explosions so that you forget the fact
that what it actually really isn't a
very good foundation the whole house is
still leading to the left because you
never figured out how to write a good
scene
it comes down to these very simple nuts
and bolts so if you watch a play you're
watching scenes on the most basic level
and you're looking at generally one or
two characters or two or five characters
or something talking
on a stage
and you're pulled in
how are they doing that what is the
magic sauce that's making all that that
scene work
it reminds me of and I think that those
filmmakers myself included if they want
to get better at this don't start by
making scenes with explosions start by
making scenes that are simple two people
in one room this is I had a friend of
mine that used to teach like a summer
camp for drummer like a music a working
musicians Camp he was a drummer he would
teach all the drummer kids and he said
the first thing he would always do on
day one is all the kids would come in
with all their drum sets and they would
set up these elaborate you know multiple
Toms and snares and this big giant sets
he would let them get all set up and
then he'd go okay
I want you to take apart your drum sets
and only give yourself one kick one
snare and one symbol
and the kids panicked because they
suddenly all their tools were taken from
them
and they had to learn how to get good at
making music with just the kick snare
and
that's tough anybody could sound great
with two kick drums but do it with just
those three little symbols same with
scene work
so how do you make a good scene work
well
it's so simple
yet it seems to be lost on a vast
majority of people
you have to be the number one thing I
think when it comes to scene work is
Clarity of goals and Stakes
Clarity that means knowing exactly I
just had a um it's so interesting I just
had a a script consultant take a look at
one of my scripts
he said to me
because what do you think you're best at
in your writing I said I think I'm
pretty good at writing action when
people read my scripts they say
um
the action is like usually really
compelling and like
he goes what do you think you struggle
with the most I say well you know
probably like the all the things in
between the little connector pieces and
the overarching like sometimes scene
work and stuff like that like exactly
what we're talking about he goes you
know why you know why they say that like
no I don't because because in action
scenes it's very clear what the
character wants they're trying to win
the motorcycle race or whatever right so
it's super easy to write this compelling
action scene because I gotta get over
the Finish Line before the other guy
does very clear goal very clear stake I
don't want to lose the race so it's a
it's a really compelling scene he goes
that's why your action scenes are
selling better it's not because you're
magical with words it's because me as an
audience member understands what he
wants when it's just husband and wife
talking about getting going shopping
it's just like because there's just
nothing there so
this is
super common and then we hear to make
all this more difficult we we are told
I don't know who tells us this I don't
know where this comes from but
um
on the nose writing right is considered
bad writing well what what
why is that
considered bad writing have you ever
wondered that why who I don't know who
initially said this but on on they say
that on the nose writing and when I say
on the nose I mean Clarity what does
your character want and where is he
going what and what is at stake if he
doesn't get it
well in order to understand what that is
that means being on the nose and very
clear I really want to get out of this
house okay
but we're told we're there's somehow in
our filmmaking Society we're told that
on the nose writing is bad well why is
that why why who who initially said that
that was a thing
I'm not sure who said it but in some
ways it doesn't let the audience really
guess and the relationship unfold it's
too it's just there's no mystery to it
you need subtext right yes we we want
this man we want it to be
um we are we want we want to be so
clever about
and making them figure it out right
well
the thing is
that's and I and I totally get that
because I'm totally wired the same way
like I don't I want to be
more clever about the way to reveal what
the character wants
but on the nose writing
what makes it that is is it almost makes
it feel that way
because when you see well done scenes
when you see a scene that just wraps you
in and pulls you right along
the writing is pretty on the nose
but they are essentially giving us
what makes things feel on the nose is
when I'll give you an example you know
you see an action like a bad action
movie and at the very beginning of the
action movie usually there's a scene
like
we got to go in and kill that guy
because he killed my sister and I'm
going to take revenge on the blah blah
and it's just long drawn out like setup
of
okay we gotta go kill the bad guy
because he killed my sister and
it it feels really clunky and on the
nose the reason why is because we didn't
ask for that information that's what
makes it feel on the nose as an audience
member you're like you're handing me all
of this stuff I didn't need
but
if you hand it to me in a way
that makes me go what is his name
then reveal it it's on the nose but it's
when I asked for it well what is it
about
this guy that bothers him what grievance
did this villain do that makes it so bad
uh
killed his sister you're revealing it at
the right time that is a real trick when
it comes to
putting a scene together properly but
where it starts is it starts with
I think
not
writing in final draft it starts with
very clear outlines and mapping
what you want so
and this is where
there's a simple goal and stake so what
I mean by that if you don't know what
that means that means like
I want to get out of the house
but the thing that's often missed is
what are the stakes of that what happens
if he doesn't
get that or she right what happens if I
don't get out of the house well if it's
just I'm gonna be bored well it's going
to be really hard for me to get behind
that as a story
you have to come up with a way to make
that
so terrifying if they don't actually get
there
um if the house is on fire
I'm gonna get third degree burns if I
don't get out of the house now that
Stakes
you know if the house has ghosts in it
you know now there's a reason to get out
of the hat like that you're you're tying
Stakes to it
um
but that's just the beginning because
you also need
someone against those
stakes and goals usually with their own
stakes and goals attached to them and if
you really want to make a scene work
you've got to come up with a way to put
those two things against each other
so I want to get out of the house
but character B wants me to go upstairs
that's a conflict
and if me going upstairs means I'm just
I'm thinking off the cuff here but like
if I want to get out of the house
because
I don't know why I'm going so dark with
this but if there's a demon that's
trying to take my soul
right so okay let's just say that's the
story there's a demon that wants to take
my soul and he's ah and I gotta get out
of the house well that's huge steaks oh
my gosh
character B walks in and says I need you
to go upstairs okay so this one now for
me like that's a huge State oh there's
no way I'm doing that
but for them okay let's imagine there's
a bigger threat outside that the outside
person sees like maybe there are zombies
outside and if you go outside you're
going to die so we need everyone to go
upstairs
now you have a conflict so that's a
scene that's that's two characters that
have two different goals and they're
they're running into each other I need
to get out of the house the other one's
going no you need to go upstairs well if
I stay in the house my soul is gonna be
taken by this demon but if you go
outside you're gonna get eaten by the
zombies well someone's gonna someone
needs should win right that's what makes
it compelling conflict now I went way
monster movie it's a horror movie or
whatever with that idea but that is
essentially the essence of what makes a
great scene taking two characters that
each have differing goals and aligning
them so that they are hitting each other
um
probably a better example would be
someone needs to get into the
um bank vault
right I need to get in there okay I'm
writing the scene I need to come up with
a way
that's my goal I have to get in the bank
vault and I don't know get my marriage
certificate out of the
that's the I get my marriage certificate
I need to go in there and I need to get
it I'm the only one with a key
you know how it works safety
safe deposit box my marriage
certificates in there I've got the key
it's Hank off to my wrist I have to be
the one to go in and unlock it and of
course you've got to have the other
usually it's two people that unlocks the
thing together you know how it works at
the bank let's say that's your goal okay
that makes sense
well how am I how do I make this goal
exciting
well we need to create someone with
opposition
all right well we can put a security
guard there now I think most people when
they would write a scene like that we
could make a security guard there that
doesn't want to let them in
okay so the security guard's there he
doesn't want to let them in the room
and you could just
oh he just lazy he doesn't want to get
off his chair and open the door I think
does that do you would you think that
that is a scene that could work and they
begin in this argument about how he's
just lazy and he just
likes his chair he just
wants to stay there do you think that
would be a scene that would work
only if I discover later that actually
he's part of a larger ring that's stolen
these marriage certificates and he's
selling them on the dark web
yeah he seems lazy and he seems innocent
enough but actually no because your
certificate is actually not in there
anymore oh that's interesting okay
and he doesn't want you to know that
so I guess if he's just lazy uh I need a
good reason why he's lazy yeah right
okay so a lot of times you'll see scenes
like this where it's like I need to get
in there to get my thing out of the
drawer well and the other person just
doesn't want to do it well and then they
break into this argument so
this is very common you'll see this kind
of scene all the time and as two people
in this argument
but what's missing there are Stakes for
both of them number one and the security
guard has no goal
like he's not really he's just
resistance he's not
he's not an antagonist necessarily so
what that's doing is it's defusing your
scene it's going to help drag it down
instead what you could do is you could
make a scenario where the security guard
has an extremely jealous wife who thinks
he's cheating on her and he and she
think you know he's supposed to stay at
his desk and just like let people into
the room
you know he tells her over and over I
got to go in there and unlock both doors
no I swear you when all the pretty girls
show up you go inside and you go in
there with him because you want to flirt
and you go in there with one more girl
and I'm Gonna Leave You and I'm gonna
sit here in the lobby and watch and make
sure that you don't now you got a
conflict he's sitting there going I
can't open I can't let you in there I
can't do it or my wife is going to leave
me and and the other character is now
getting in now you have two characters
with two separate goals that are
slamming into each other this is very
very
um it sounds so simple to do but this is
where it's important to like really
outline and put on a I like putting it
on a big white board
you know your directions that your
characters are going and make them go
into each other and then more
importantly attach Stakes to each one of
them if I don't get into that safe
deposit box to get the
whatever
marriage certificate if I don't get that
I can't prove that I was
I'll lose my inheritance if I can't show
that I whatever
okay
now you have steaks and then you put the
security guard where his marriage is
going to fall apart if he lets you in
great
you can almost feel the tension go up
you can feel it on set too
when you have a scene that has these
kinds of things attached to it the
actors relish it like they can
immediately you feel it come alive you
can feel it right how you can just
suddenly the tension goes up you haven't
even started working on
escalations and how you you suddenly amp
up the tension in a scene like that or
adding and Ticking you know
it's 4 59 and it closes at five we
haven't even gotten there yet it's just
two characters with goals now it gets a
lot easier to to really make a scene
work that's where it always begins
that's that's the initial building box
did you see uh come back to the five and
dime uh Jimmy Dean Robert Altman it's
based on a play it's from 1982 or
something so it's just one room it's a
Woolworth in like Marfa Texas
and all the characters it's all women uh
except for one man and he's in and out
it's kind of a memory and the just the
subtleties that it's not on the nose but
you learn about the characters then you
learn about their Petty gripes and
jealousies with one another you learn
about the small town gossip all of it is
slowly revealed until the real story
finally comes out but it it's so
excellent and you're just there riveted
and it's one location
yeah writing scenes in one location is
especially simple ones with just
character driven with no fancy tricks it
is the most challenging thing but I do
believe that that's where all scenes
should begin
no matter if they're in space or some
sci-fi time travel epic or not because
that's a foundation
right now if you never go into outer
space or back in time and you stay in
the room with the Woolworths
you don't have any way to wave your
hands around to distract the audience
that you have nothing does that make
sense like so
I think that if you really want to
create more complex sci-fi stories you
need to really get good really good at
writing those simple
start writing scenes with two characters
each of them has something that they
want only one of them can win
both of them can lose write a scene like
that that's a page Turner and you're
going to be amazing at writing the Big
Space Opera like
it's hard to do but it's that's so if
you want to make it as a screenwriter
that's you have to master that